hey guys how's it going so we're gonna
do a quick little unboxing of the Legend
of Zelda Twilight Princess I am
extremely excited about this not gonna
lie mostly for the amiibo this is the
wolf link amiibo it looks amazing and it
allows you to access different parts of
the cave of shadows most of you guys
know if you're not new here that I'm
completely amiibo obsessed I've been
promising you guys forever to do an
amiibo collection video but every time I
go to film it
I just think oh I have an amiibo coming
tomorrow I'll just wait and just hold on
so the complete collection when I have
them all except here's the problem new
ones keep coming out which is not a bad
problem but it is a problem because I
have to stop at some point like this
can't keep going on forever I mean at
what point do I say okay enough is
enough is it when I run out of room is
it when my sister revokes access to all
of my credit card so I no longer be able
to purchase that I mean they've already
sort of been doing duplicate amiibo
because they had the Super Smash
Brothers and then they had the Super
Mario version ones as well so there's
sort of duplicate characters so there's
some for the kirby series coming out in
June new Animal Crossing cards are
already coming out Oh Isabel she's
coming out with a summer outfit because
her winter outfit clearly wasn't good
enough there's another six that are
coming out this month anyway this video
is about our Twilight Princess
let's open we've got game and we've got
our wolf link oh it looks good it's a
big amiibo - this isn't late or not go
small on this one
[Music]
it's big it's real bad
you look weddings let me know if any of
you guys have been playing this game yet
I'm probably gonna start it tonight
although I still have far cry and fire
watch that I wanted to play and I have
not had time I haven't even got a chance
to play fallout yet plus my free time
I've been playing Call of Duty like
usual
mostly because I know if I don't have a
lot of time I can just play a couple of
free-for-all matches and I feel like I
got my fix of video game playing it and
of course I'm always street passing
pretty much 24/7 is gonna be kind of
interesting to see where Nintendo goes
as far as the mobile space is concerned
because for me mobile gaming is where I
sort of end up doing most of my gaming
now because with traveling and it's so
easy and portable you just always have a
device with you let me know your guys's
thoughts
here's my dog he's still in his cone
I'll see you at the next video and
tomorrow for a flying cooking video I
believe I am making a burrito yeah it
pumped see you then bye
well today we're gonna be chatting about
the new iphone 7 pro now this room were
sort of popped up the past couple of
days and I was reading about it
yesterday and I was getting really
really excited